[Music]
welcome to air biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
exploring the question is back to school
a feeling interesting because it's that
time of year actually today is that time
of day for our families this morning's
first day of school when all of our kids
went back to school and wait it's really
it brought up a lot of experiences I've
had because every year for a lot of my
life I'd go back to school mmm-hmm me
too
and was there I didn't drop out was
there a was there is don't drop out
don't drop out was there a specific
feeling associated with that if there
was what was it or what also now still
is it because it still happened even
though we are no longer going to school
and I don't just mean vicariously
through our kids I think we can we can
take a journey through the kids but also
through our own yeah appearance will be
talking about even we're gonna get into
a little bit just a little bit not too
much science as to why you may still
feel that back-to-school feeling even
after you no longer go to school and
we're going to be recollecting can you
use that term in that way rush electing
yeah reminiscing about some of our
specific calling back to school
experiences that we had which of course
many of those were shared because we
went to school and back to school
basically every year that we went to
school with the exception of like one
but yeah but let's talk about the
children because I think before we do we
have to issue an apology oh yeah
fact-check we have to do what do you
call it an error correction we got to do
a correction moment here on your
biscuits you know what we never said
that everything that I say is perfect I
think Rhett tends to imply by his tone
of voice it you dairy they think when I
said it that you that I was the one that
was wrong or saying something that you
that you only speak truth no any results
I don't want to have to
to eclipse Dyson is from Australia
that's why Dyson is Australian for
vacuuming isn't that are you sure that
Dyson is from Australia
pretty sure look that up can you verify
that no you note if you recall I
specifically said I think is I think
Dyson is from Australia but then I was
like at least I think it's from
Australia and then I said and then we
said Jacob check that because we had the
wherewithal in the moment to know that
and I had the wherewithal and you know
what I respect you for that
you didn't do that with fact check and
say you know what I don't want to say it
I really thought they were from
Australia and then he did the fact check
and you know he's actually not in here
to defend himself I'm gesturing to where
he normally would be he's not in here
right now
he came back with you know why he's not
in here because he was wrong he should
been Shane he used his keyboard he used
his laptop and Jacob doesn't like to
speak audibly while in here I mean he's
not mute he does yeah he does speak when
he when he when he works the only one
spoken to no well we spoke to he likes
to just type so as not to interrupt the
flow of our and I appreciate that and he
said something to the effect of James
Dyson is from Australia but the fact is
he's not and that's why he's not here
Jacob no longer work so that's what
happens around here when you make a
mistake like that when you make us look
bad you get fired
you've gone actually just on a phone
call he still works here he's doing
something more important than we see
here and and I will put this in quotes
fat because it's actually a British
company we are sorry to everyone in
England we know that you are actually
responsible for Dyson well at least your
country is you're not and maybe are
listen if you are actually a Dyson and
we apologise but they're dudes Australia
and we learn what we were in Australia
that Australia there you like why did
that there is still a connection
technically they're still under the
authority right of the United Kingdom
not independent there's something else
Jacob can you what our long he's not in
here why is he not okay yeah if Jacob
were here right now he would be typing
and they are independent but it's not
quite
sorry guys perfect independence he he
doesn't he looked he very quickly you
know we put him on the spot he was
acting
he was listening but he was doing
something more important and then we put
him on the spot and he like he did some
google but he did it in a faulty way
yeah apparently because something came
up that talked about all of these
production facilities and things in
Australia but the headquarters is in the
UK yeah I think there's a better way to
apologize sorry we took for that usually
to say last on last week's podcast we
incorrectly stated that Dyson was from
Australia we are sorry we now know that
it is from England and then you just
move on we could have just done that
punitive measures were taken but we're
not gonna go into details and we're not
gonna we're not gonna ridicule someone
who's not here we wouldn't do that let's
talk about the fact that alright we just
sent our children off to school and
again last year was their first time
ever going to public school they they
were all homeschooled so last year was
was huge I mean they were we worried
about so many things like living
transition Lilly was going into being a
freshman in high school and how many how
many students are at their high school
retha almost 3,000 yeah 3,000 students
at one high school which is three times
the number that we had it H CHS Harnett
Central High School can you imagine just
beat I mean she wasn't physically just
schooled at home up until 8th grade
there was like they went to others there
were classes taking a charter school
type situation there was there was
social interaction yeah yeah yeah we
didn't keep him in a cage but it was um
it wasn't it was not a public school
setting and there was nowhere near three
thousand kids no so a big transition for
them and of course I mean it was first
time lando beam and seven years old at
the time I mean all the kids your kids
too it was like there was a lot of
wigging out happening like Locke was
good you know it's a big deal for him
and Lincoln and yeah it was just you
know they were trying to find their way
in the world and they all adjusted
incredibly well they had a really good
first year they you know if it wasn't
super ins wasn't super easy found
hobbies but they got plugged in and they
were you know they it wasn't about the
unknown this year now it was a little
bit for for my oldest Locke because he
was beginning his freshman year at high
school
but you know he knows a lot of the
people who are from the school because
it's mostly the one school going to the
next school so it's not like for us
which we'll talk about a little bit
whereas all bunch of schools coming
together so last year a whole bunch of
worries this year the only worry that I
could discern was what are we gonna wear
on the first day of school yeah you know
last night I got home from work and that
you know the whole place was abuzz like
everyone was running around getting all
their stuff straight and Kristy was
packing the lunches and she was she was
clandestinely writing it right in a note
she's a notre huh
she wrote a note and then she my mom was
an odor she was like I walked through
the kitchen she was like wouldn't you
like to write a little note to Lando
pressure notes
yeah pressure me into writing a note so
I wrote him a little note where'd you
say huh I said this signature is
probably worth something on ebay and
then I stuck it inside of his well okay
he may still happen playing off of the
narcissism joke that you just made I
will say that as a fellow narcissist I I
have found myself I didn't actually I
didn't write a note I wrote a note
yesterday to Shepherd because it was his
birthday so we usually get them a book
and we write in we take a page in the
book and and write in the book and
that's like their card and their thing
and we talk about things that happening
in that year but multiple times that
I've been writing notes to my children I
get to the end and I begin to sign it
Rhett he's like yeah I haven't quite a
bit so but why do you do that because
I'm you know because I'm super popular
and people just demand to have my
signature that's where the narcissism
comes in but nobody I started no no no
I'm not read I'm dead Inara is easily
turned into like a Adi Adi with the legs
yeah yeah I made it work many times you
make that D walk okay but anyway I so
this yeah I'm moving right on right
along the same thing was happening at my
house it was there was a lot of hustle
and bustle because you know on Sunday
they had gone out in the
done their back to school shopping
mmm-hmm they go you got a shop the
clothes that they wanted that's the
first thing about back to school is that
it's a it's a commercial event I mean
it's like frickin Black Friday yeah well
it's kind of like when we get ready for
him I got a pencil or two but I got to
get 12 more today we get ready for a new
season a good mythical morning we're
like we gotta get we gotta get some new
clothes
be happy wearing too many some shirts
too many times that you don't want to do
that at school a tasting point okay the
back-to-school feeling I think that's
that's a good data point right there
that because we still love it well
because we have started our show at the
same time that back-to-school happens
right it's just the way that it's worked
out and so I think that's one of the
reasons that we continued to ingrain
that pattern in our brains for years but
but because the show is so structured
around being a part of the daily routine
of the viewers right we want to be in
sync with that we try to take a little
break and then I am bring it back around
that same time when people are adopting
their their their scheduled rhythm you
know right well I will say that I it
sounds like you were more involved last
night than I was and this is where I got
into a little I mean I wrote that you
wrote notes you brought pressure notes
but you wrote notes oh you got in
trouble yeah this is what happened with
me is that I got home and there's lots
um first of all it was Shepherds
birthday so we'd like did a birthday
dinner I grilled the steaks I mean I
thought that was pretty noble and and so
and then Jesse's like all right you guys
got to get ready you got to get your
clothes out and it just kind of seemed
like everything was under control it
just sort of seemed like everything was
working like a well-oiled machine and so
I was like I'm going to get in the hot
tub no yeah yeah because I was like my
legs were sore my legs are sore man I
think I did I did one-legged squats on
Monday you know shout out to the gym
that I go to I first workouts it's being
back since from Australia in Fiji okay
so see it's you're adopting again
that school getting back in the routine
but so I was like I wanted to soak my
sore legs I go out into the hot tub I
have you know just sort of some moments
with myself and then I come back in less
than an hour later and she's like where
have you been and I was thinking what
isn't it obvious I'm soaking wet and
very relaxed I've been in no I said I've
been in the hot tub but but at that
point you were like what kind of say no
no I said Shepard told me to turn it on
because we've been playing hold the
whole day was about Shepard in his
birthday you do whatever Shepherd
shepherd toy Shepherds are in the hot
tub on I thought he would come out and
get in alone
he didn't she wasn't happy with me I
apologize baby I'm sorry I didn't
participate you didn't you were
apologizing now no no no no I apologize
multiple times last night but it she I
was kind of met with an icy stare
because she just continued to do things
now here I'm faced with a decision
because I I could decide to say at this
point I actually got in my hot tub last
night but then what would happen is I
would you I would be it yes I would be
at Mitty you got it here here's the
thing I would be admitting that I own a
hot tub Yeah right and I you know
whenever you said in you've already
you've already admitted to having a hot
tub in like another podcast I think and
I just kind of you have a bigger hot tub
I get I got stay here yeah you have a
hot tub i morning self caught you have a
hot tub you have a hot tub that changes
color while we all sit it like it goes
from like green to blue to orange it's
like an alien abduction yeah you have a
hot tub that's bigger and cooler than
mine of course I am getting my backyard
redone so mine will be bigger and cooler
than yours and not-too-distant future
keep going back before I made the
narcissism joke a few minutes ago and
then we start talking about our kids and
then you make you your self deprecated
you tell about how you know you're
telling this story I'm just really
self-conscious about it's fine listen
ace is making a joke about being a noise
hole then like being a narcissist what
telling that you are gonna not like us
because we have hot tubs and we are
constantly trying to make them big
I'm better than each others they can
just move on there's other people who do
things on the internet it's fine okay
what I will say is I remember the time
that our friend Michael growing up
called our friend Erik growing up and
Eric's dad answered the phone I remember
Michael telling us this story and he
said he called him and he was like hello
mister so-and-so can I speak to Eric and
he was like oh I'm sorry Michael Eric's
in the hot tub and so for I remember for
years feeling that like someone being in
the hot tub and not being able to come
to the phone was a huge douche move so I
completely understand your your aversion
to douchey vibes yeah a lot of douchey
but I mean cuz cuz when you drop just
like oh we always in my hot tub last
night in Bubba but it's like it's like
name-dropping it's like a big bathtub
really it's just like a big bathtub
outdoors with lights that change now
mine stays the same
my life does not change this is pretty
low right I just how I'm gonna defend my
hot tub this is what's gonna make me
feel better about it and this is true
it's one of my favorite places to be I'm
like a king in there you see you had
some special moments to yourself as well
last night actually know a great thing
about our hot tub is we're like a dinner
I'm like you guys you want me to heat up
the hot tub and I have to get agreement
from like the majority of the family and
then and tell them how easy it is for
you to heat the hot tub of leg so my
phone right here when I get home what a
douche it's hot what a douche can just
pick his phone I need and change the
temperature I can't even do that
I have valves that I have to maneuver
now I will be able to control it with my
mind come January but so if the majority
says yes we'll get in the hot tub
they're my okay we're all getting in a
hot tub and it becomes like it's like um
it's great family time
it's like gathering around the campfire
we do it all the time which of course I
also have one of those you do yeah you
have a freaking fire you have two fire
pits you have a fire pit next to your a
hot tub that's just a bowl of fire that
you like just for effect
you have pyrotechnics in your backyard
don't embarrass me about my fire listen
hold on I just let go man I know it just
to be enjoying my show it's the fruits
of your labor man you've worked hard for
over a decade you have a freakin fire on
that side can't a man have his fire yeah
I'm getting four fire pits I'm gonna
have gargoyles that breathe fire all
around the entire perimeter of my
property uses towel dryer uh III just
I've stood over that cauldron of fire
next to my hot tub make him naked yeah
wait there I just guess I would have a
towel and I'd be drying off I'd be
drying off and then I would just open
the towel like and receive the flames
like a creepy like a creepy watch
salesman on like a street corner in New
York City that's where they do that and
I was just like I would Corral the fire
around my my region yeah yeah nothing
like that and just like dry it off that
way here I can't wait to do that with
the gargoyle get the right angle on that
I'm gonna ride the gargoyle like I'm
spitting fire so last night they all
agreed and we all got in the hot tub and
and we in it's because it's a great time
it's kind of like the dinner table
you're sitting there no screens allowed
you're not in front of the television or
whatever so all you all you can do is
hold your breath or talk to each other
right so so we you know it's a great
place for us to connect as a family and
talk to each other and not being
narcissistic or a douche right yeah so
we did that last night we talked about
the expect everyone's expectation is
what they were looking forward to but
again it just came back to what they
were gonna wear like Lincoln ordered
these shoes off and she was such a big
deal
get other white shoes lock really got
Lincoln into like the shoes he's very
aware like luck is kind of like an older
brother in that way that like okay tell
me tell me what what's what and what I
should be into III he didn't tell me
that I'm just kind of reading between
the lines but anyway there were shoes
and then he was like dad I
I don't have socks that are just the
right amount of no-show I'll go with my
shoes for the first day of school
emergency trip to the store no I was
like
I got to cover Sun I can I got two
different options in my sock drawer but
I want to lend you for this I really do
with low tops really came through low
tops yeah yeah Locke went with the low
tub any pot vans and he said I'm gonna
wear my shorts which are there there
what that white they're like cool shorts
with like a white base is what he said
so he's like he thought about all this
yep that's it so then the next morning
this is what happens so they're all so
everybody's scrambling to get ready and
then everybody's getting rushed out the
door and Chris is like oh no no we got
it we got to take the picture we got to
take the picture you got to have the
picture and so they go out at the front
door to take the picture outside because
jesse is coming with Locke and Shepard
to pick up Lily to take Lily with to
high school with Locke for lux first day
like you know Lily will be there and
kind of show him a little bit of the
ropes right she's been there a year so I
go out the front door I mess up the
picture because they were already trying
to take it and then I'm cuz I wanted to
watch i watch them take the picture and
I notice about the same time that Jesse
pulls up and rolls down the window the
same thing that Locke noticed which is
my son's hair is huge like it he's he
spends a lot of time on it and he he
like he like poofed it up and I mean
it's like my hair kind of but like twice
as tall yeah and blonde and Locke rolls
down his window and he's like Lincoln
your hair is insane
and then Crissy starts taking the
pictures Lily gets in the car they drive
off we wave goodbye you go back in we're
going back in the house and I hear
Lincoln say to himself he's like I got
it I got to do something about my hair I
got
I thought of taking it too far too
insane
I think Locke minute as a compliment
like insane is good yeah get a big grin
on his face but like you know you're so
self-conscious in that first day
everything's got to be peak in perfect
some light I'll help you out son so like
he goes back in there for a second
blow-drying session and I'm like trying
to get helping get it right and stuff
you brought it down you tone it down a
lot yeah took it to the side a little
bit want to see how it turned out we
worked it I haven't gotten home yet I've
done some texting with the family and
I've got some updates on how they did
maybe I'll save that for the end before
I get in a hot tub yeah my tummy after
I'm done with it
my kids didn't like actually ended up
getting a haircut
yeah his hair has cut Lincoln's hair
last night - oh yeah you by the way but
just the side I don't do that you know i
have i have a small sort of humble hot
tub and also don't as if that would be a
douche thing to do I cut I cut Chrissy's
hair too I use bulk but like I ended up
cutting his hair because he's been kind
of growing it out and he's been doing al
is you know he's been like kind of
putting it when he gets a little bit
long because he's playing basketball so
he's like kind of puts it back almost
it's not really a man bun but it's the
beginning of one well that's a pre man
bun but the basketball coach saw that
and said uh-uh nope don't even think
about it they don't allow it and while
he could have protested because you can
try mean I don't really know what the
rules are
he was like I just I got it cut because
I didn't want to you know immediately
they talked about a little bit but
ultimately he was I don't you know
trying to trying to establish myself and
so made it a little bit shorter so so
they both had to tone their hair down
okay I had to tone it down you ain't
going and going into the next year you
got to tone it down you want to make a
statement on that first day I mean your
clothes do matter because it it's that
part of that confidence cuz you want to
be able to slide in there with a little
strut and you're walking you got to
bring your best on day one from you
don't have to yeah you could set
expectations a little bit like day two
thing who is that
I don't yes every day that's why that's
why the school uniforms I mean that's
why a lot of schools do the uniform so
because you just take that completely
out there is no opportunity to express
yourself in that way I don't know
there's advantages of disadvantages
that's not what we're gonna talk about
we're talking about back-to-school and
we're gonna talk about us going back to
school year after year in a moment but
first we want to pause and let you know
that you can get the shirt that link is
wearing a mythical dot store look at
that says ear biscuits which is the name
of this podcast never heard of that
yeah I've heard of it hosted by a couple
of douches with hot tubs
yeah those douche hot tub guys how hot
can your tub yeah legal limit 104 except
the other day I saw it creeped up to 105
good combos called 911 I've never gone
over ninety six or seven man I can't
take it oh my wife likes it hot that's
why she married me but she likes the hot
tub to be 104 which is the legal limit
and it's like it is like getting into a
witch's brew it is incredibly I don't
cook you yeah yeah and I so that's how
hot it will get but I keep it at 98 when
it is just me and my long I don't think
you should let kids in there at that
temperature by the way oh my god my kids
are tough man I'm toughening I'm talking
about sperm sperm makers I've made all
the kids I I guess you don't want you
talk about them hey you want to
sterilize your children I don't think
that I don't think that that is really a
long-term risk we're still we're still
in like the March promo buy them oh yeah
this is like a video exclusive thank you
for watching the video version weary
soldiers and made a PSA so maybe we'll
just make a which make a hot tub shirt
I'm a douche
I own a hot tub yeah let's not put the
word douche on a t-shirt really that's
that's not tasteful okay oosh get all
types of get all types of stuff to
support entertainment and show your self
including these bracelets that were
wearing we've got all new mythical
bracelets and
new color scheme that we are that we are
rocking these days I don't know what
which it's not really quite pastels I
don't know what you would call it but
you know it's cool kids love it a couple
of douches where I'm all the time
mythical dot store thank you
so we were just talking a second ago
because we have so many things that we
remember together about the way that we
that we remember back to school but the
cool thing is is that one of my earliest
back-to-school experiences ever that I
remember vividly is our first day of
first grade which is when we actually
met yeah that was like the ultimate back
to back to school is like the basis of
our friendship yeah cuz I mean yeah well
here was the thing at Buies Creek course
I was there for kindergarten which
wasn't wasn't great for me I mean you
know it was good I wasn't there I hey
I'm sure that the first day of school
was always laced with anxiety for me
because I mean that's just I know enough
about myself even though I can't
remember specifics I I do know that my
mom would take the first day of school
picture at the end of the hallway there
was there was the closet that had the
towels in it nice white background yeah
she would put me against that and she'd
take my photo with like my lunchbox I
remember you had a Qbert lunchbox
I remember the Qbert lunchbox that must
have been first grade I'm pretty sure I
had a he-man Masters of the Universe
lunch buy I remember your lunchbox it
was blue and I was holding it in my
first day of school shot and I think I
can see the anxiety in my eyes on all of
those pick I remembered not for me I was
coming from California and yeah cuz I
lived I lived in California for three
years down the road in Thousand Oaks
before moving to North Carolina in first
grade and I I don't know I wasn't an
anxious kid I never dealt with a lot of
anxiety and I actually remember
especially in subsequent years always
the only time I was excited about school
was the first day of school that was
when I was like this is I'm come
make my way I'm gonna establish myself
and this is I saw this excitement not
anxiety but just anticipation and
excitement and then it's like day two
I'd be like ah school sucks and I was
one of those school sucks kind of guys
from then on uh but I do remember you
loved a newness man III remember anxiety
over that because I was this new kid in
this small town it was very different
from where I'd come from I do remember
thinking that my Qbert lunchbox Lite
said something about me though so I
these were all play his they don't know
about Qbert yes did not know about I'm
gonna blow their minds with Qbert this
little this little guy with a with a
snout and he goes up the pyramid oh
they're gonna be blown away by this no
one mentioned it was that on Atari
because I think that was just in arcades
I had Qbert I feel like I had Qbert on a
home system or something I don't think
he did it was on Atari wasn't it I don't
think it was see fellas looking that up
right now we're gonna see what kind of
fact checker he is but to think about
buoys Korean symbol definitely was I was
now that was a new the version on
Nintendo I think was a new iteration but
like the arcade version that was on his
lunchbox was like yeah brought us an
arcade game yeah I just had the lunchbox
at home and made me think I had a
console thing about Buies Creek was such
a small town such a small school every
year we you would specifically
anticipate who's gonna be the new kid
you know cuz there's usually only one or
two maybe three if things got crazy
right but I mean people were not pouring
into this town and when they moved in
everybody knew it when you get load up
oh this girl's from Nebraska what that's
crazy there's somebody from another
state like that was what it was like
when people moved in but the most
significant year for me when you talk
about new students was sixth grade Miss
Linear's class when guy both both Leslie
and amber who have who carried great
significance in both of our lives here
we are talking about them again less
our first girlfriend Amber first kissed
different times they both came to the
school in the same year and boy you know
first of all from about first great look
like first grade on
I thought about girls most of the time
most of my brain was was being devoted
towards women oh you can get it for $12
I can get a cube root is that Cuban
lunchbox okay for the Atari okay I'm
wrong
that's the Atari 2600 I had the Atari
2600 oh you did I did that was I had
that before Nintendo so you cared about
girls with like 99.9% of your being and
with that well it was asked and
increased slowly but 6.1% it was Cuba
sixth grade my body was beginning to
change oh I just look I changed a little
bit earlier and so that didn't that made
the the reception of two new interesting
ladies it was doing he was doing things
to me he was serious it was different it
was more intense than it had been before
I was beside myself and that's where
that's the year that miss Lanier decided
to put us into I was like this is weird
but she decided to seat us clusters in
clusters of four facing each other so
like you got four kids and they're all
facing each other and their desks are
kind of touching at the top group work
and that was when I did though I've told
this story before I'll tell the
abbreviated version but that was when I
just decided one day she had shorts on I
had shorts on I was like I I'm going to
connect my knee to her knee as a show of
affection which I do not recommend it
was sixth grade I didn't ask for consent
it was also like 1986 it was a different
time whatever I don't know what year was
that's that's not an excuse I'm going on
the record to say I don't know what what
you it was just knee to knee contact I
just feel like I have to quite the you
know it just brushed your kneecap
against her kneecap I well I know I
brushed my knee against her kneecap but
when she pulled back I brushed it again
I got long legs I got a lot to give and
she did she report
in recoil or did she just think that oh
he did that backs and she did not
repulse she did not recoil she just
moved away gently and then after the
third or fourth time of contact I would
she was like wow Rhett you got some long
legs she said that and then and I kind
of gave her oh looks like you bet I do
and then you like kept your knee graze
dig like that's no longer graze that's a
best III at that point I pull back and
then within a week we were dating so
okay it worked
I and again I don't recommend it I'm
just telling a story news of this
trickled to the library where I was
being being very bookish one day because
I was in miss Campbell's class
it wasn't miss Campbell's class right or
miss Ryan's you and miss Campbell's
class sixth grade yeah yeah I had to
wait a whole year to date Lesley after
that yeah yeah okay so anyway I know
what I got to do is just a matter of
time that's all I was thinking about but
what started with Lesley is now about
hot tub sighs yeah but but Lesley Ann
amber were both new kids and I think
that's that's what they were very close
friends I think that was the factor but
you know they assimilated yeah but
that's the type of thing you were
looking for every year was who's gonna
be new where they gonna come from what's
their knee cap gonna feel like when my
kneecap touches it you know you know it
could be anything
yeah really freshness new beginnings the
ability to start over I think was so
great aye-aye-aye
I remember thinking with every new
school year I can I can be somebody else
I can but not reinvent myself but not
but not really because you were the same
kid that didn't go into school with the
same kids but but you know who did it
one person was able in the tight-knit
community of Louise and recess from one
school year to the next
reinvented himself chip oh yeah he was
chipping than he was Peter yes
into one school year he was chip
beginning in the next school year call
me Peter yeah and it took a while to
stick
I caught him chip for I he was my
neighbor so and this is I held on the
chip for two years and this is the Peter
Dinklage that it if you came to our show
this is the Peter Dinklage that was rets
neighbor yeah and not that Peter
Dinklage that you're thinking about my
we're doing the one that was formerly
known as chip yeah dinkler which which
first of all I understand that you
minute upset because I didn't understand
until later in life maybe like a couple
years later that chip is a nickname is
like chip off you know it's like junior
chip off it
yeah off the old block and so it when
when a boy wants to become a man and
establish himself he wants to become
Peter the problem is is his dad was also
named Peter so I mean it's sort of like
you know but at least he was he was
added go to school with him he didn't
write home a drunk CAPRISA but the
bigger what you remember what year that
was when chip became Peter because
you're saying he became a man but this
was not like fourth or fifth great yeah
yeah but I mean you know right before he
became a man
depends on what culture you're in and
what your what your what your experience
is eighth grade I want to talk about
with your neighbor so hey I have a spot
he didn't live in the outback 8th grade
first of all we went to Bowie screech
school it was K through eighth which is
not very common anymore in fact we were
the last yeah this is us the last 8th
grade class ever it Buies Creek
Elementary School after that it turned
into Harnett Central Middle School where
all the schools that didn't go to
harness central high school come
together yeah so then Belews Creek
Elementary then and now still does only
goes through 5th grade 5th grade yes so
we had spent all this time in fact I
remember in first grade going to the
talent show in the Buies Creek called
auditorium and watching the 8th graders
at the time perform brass monkey that
was the peak man and it was Brad Inman
shoutout to Brad him and wherever you
are up there playing the trumpet
during brass monkey and it was unreal it
was I remember sitting there watching
this happen and thinking you cannot get
any cooler than this group of eighth
graders up there right now doing my
trumpet they did it they changed it to
bass trumpet trumpet and then he did a
trumpet solo brass trumpet it literate
blew my mind I'm not literally what I do
I stop myself from saying literally
because I don't want to misuse the term
literally it figuratively blew my mind
yeah it the bookends to the year the the
best moments of the year the feelings
that if you just want to bottle up and
just binge drink is that first day of
school and then the day of the talent
show because that everything after that
it was only like maybe another week of
school maybe some exams and stuff which
sucked but yeah in it so your point is
you're all you the whole student body
goes and watches the talent show to end
the school year and you got these eighth
graders man well I'm thinking about the
way that we perceived 8th graders in the
way that it impacted my first day of a
great yes you remember when we did your
book day it was a big thing for the kids
you wait in line to get it to get get
Chris Stewart I remember Chris Stewart
yes who was an eighth grade when I think
when we were in he was four he was four
years older than us no he was a senior
when we were freshmen in high school so
he was three years older actually he
wasn't that close no no it was older
than my brother not your I I'm thinking
of the others Chris Chris Johnson Chris
Johnson no Chris Stewart wasn't eighth
grader when we were like in first grade
yet yep yep and so I remember going up
to him and standing in line waiting for
him to sign my yearbook and he just like
sign like a celebrity Chris Stewart even
his younger sister Natalie you had to
stand in line yeah I get her autograph
for Stuart just sign my yearbook it was
like Tom Cruise had signed my yearbook
and so when I walked into Buies Creek
Elementary sign Oh Tom Cruise does sign
all of his own year but he does when I
walked into those halls
those hallowed halls the Buies Creek
Elementary as an eighth grader I
realized that all of these kids were
seeing me the way that I saw Chris
Stewart as a god and I was like I can do
anything
III own this place we're gonna do the
talent show we're gonna do Digital
Underground it's gonna be incredible and
and I mean I don't I don't know if this
ruled the school man if it lived up to
those expectations that we set but I
remember signing kids yearbooks yeah and
I think I think there's I can I can draw
a direct line from that to the hot tub I
know you know it's like got trying to
recapture that feeling man
constantly you know she's trying to give
I get it the biggest transition the
back-to-school moment was going into
high school because I mean now you're
not ruling campus anymore you're not an
eighth grader at a school that you spent
your basically your entire life going to
but you're going off to this high school
it was nerve-racking because it was huge
it was a melting pot of all of the
elementary schools because there were no
middle schools in the county so you had
boys Creek Elementary where we came from
and we had the reputation as being the
smart kids well and let me explain that
a little bit just the Buies Creek
mentality was that we were in the middle
of this County Harnett County and we
were where the university was where
Campbell University was and a lot of us
like me and my dad taught at the law
school still does and so so you weren't
from a farming we had this sense that we
were better than everybody just because
we were like we knew we were in the
middle of nowhere but we're like but at
least we have a university we are this
bastion of Education and so we kind of
looked down on all the other little
towns that were just normal southern
towns around us cuz you had you had
Lafayette school which I always thought
of them as they were kind of good old
boys they were all really nice more
farmer oriented lots of farmers but they
had a really good band I knew some of
the band members like I'd met them and
said we did some cross-pollination bein
a good band huh I didn't know that yeah
they had never noticed the love bands
quality trumpet Keith Sears
Keith Sears he played I played trumpet
trumpet great great guy one of the best
guys uh once you got to know those
Lafayette boys they were great joseph
riffles oh man the piano mustache he had
a mustache in like fourth grade know him
look at you legs like tree trunks yeah I
just walk up to him and talk to his
mustache he had huge care I wouldn't
even talked to him and he was so nice
that was love yeah then he had
Lillington Lillington was like Buies
Creek adjacent right so yeah so we kind
of like we're like okay you guys you
have like you've got your own like Town
Hall and you are the county seat right
so you have that you're the county seat
this is where the courthouse is you've
got some bragging rights you know you're
not Buies Creek but you're you're good
you're good
you'd walk you you you'd always eat we'd
go to Lillington to eat like to go to
the McDonald's well that's where the
hearty foods where that's where food
exists we had no place to eat up little
Dino's all right and that was only open
for a while you passed by the sexton
Ford car lot yeah and then lo and behold
you start going to the high school you
realize chad sexton goes to the high
school there's an actual sexton that i
now go to school with drive past that
used-car lot anymore it's like and you
know there's a connection a connection
sexton is probably one of the best last
names of anybody any kid who would have
to be in a well I don't know it's a lot
to live up to a high school but then you
had Andrew and we're gonna say about
Andrew tread lightly
yourself would angel because scrappy
they were scratch scrappy I'm sort of
yeah they knew they knew stuff and they
they knew stuff that we did they knew
they and they had substances that we did
that's right yeah Andrew was a little
rougher well rougher around the edges
yeah yeah
but Jason Keenan was a great friend of
my guy to meet taught us a lot but
Andrew was wear harness Central High
School was so we had to basically go to
Andrew I mean it was like give him some
respect west Andrew in order to go to
school so all of a sudden were grouped
together and there's all these ideas
again for me feels like gang warfare
it's like going into first your first
you know how it is your first day in
prison and you're figuring out the
different gangs and I will say that for
the majority of our entire high school
career we kind of stayed with that Buies
Creek group we let a few other people in
and I'm very tight-knit I'm not proud of
this it was it was it was almost it
wasn't purposely cliquey but the school
was but it was as clicky as most ninety
schools were I think it probably is
still the same but we it was a pretty
night League tightly knit group but
again the only supposed to a nightly tip
the nightly tick group is that only
happen in age you know that's weird
that's just breast feeding babies oh the
nightly tick group so what I remember
thinking again I was thinking yeah I was
in I was in complete overdrive by this
time thinking about girls going into my
freshman year and I and I remember we
would get together we would go to the
river we spent a lot of time in the Cape
Fear River swimming and we would have
some of our deepest most significant
conversations while just swimming in the
river they weren't all about women a lot
of them were look I'm saying one thing
I'm thinking about what I'm thinking
about like anticipating what high school
was gonna be like and of course you know
I the way I smell their morning about
summer I have a way of sensationalizing
things and trying to make things seem
like they're gonna be incredible and I
was like to think I was like we're gonna
go do you think you don't understand
it's like sure you know we've been here
with this group and but now we're gonna
have there's gonna be and your girls let
me tell you about Andrew girls there's
gonna be Lafayette girls there's gonna
be Lillington girls the girls that we
have not been able to see because we go
we can't go to those public pools you
know what I'm saying right we can't we
go to Keith Hills pool
go to these other pools right and so I
was really building it up in my mind
that was the only thing that I was
thinking about and I was thinking what's
the structure of this I mean this is a
big place how do I know how to get
around okay I'm not gonna I'm gonna
print out my schedule and put it in
multiple places because I don't know if
I'm gonna I don't wanna get a loss
printed out how would you have done that
well they mailed it to you I don't I
it was the mentality okay I understand
I'm not trying to poke holes I don't
think I had a try not to poke holes into
you remember even your dot-matrix life I
still I mean I know that I still have my
class schedule from every year because I
was very anxious about going to the
wrong class at the wrong time you still
have them I have like an envelope that
has stuff from every year of my school
as wild and I have including your class
schedule because I would keep even
though I I would eventually master it
but there was like a commons area and
that there were places where you could
buy drinks yeah vending machines outside
yeah and you could go in the cafeteria
and there were multiple lines it's like
this was crazy you want to just get
pizza you just want a chicken sandwich
or do you want the daily offering there
was a pit outside it was like picture an
amphitheater that only has three steps
that's what I call a pit because they
called it a pit where you could smoke
yeah we had a smoking pit designated
smoking area at right beside everyone
who walked into the school walked right
past it yeah I notice any direction you
looked literally was a tobacco yeah so
we were just supporting the local
industry I mean I did not partake I did
not smoke I didn't either but in high
school but there's a quite a few that
did it was a it was a very new world and
it was you know is that you looked at it
with so much promise in it and a chance
to connect with in a love what life kind
of way well I specifically remember not
the first day of school but before the
first day of school there was some sort
of sports banquet or raffle or something
that my brother was going to because my
brother was already on the basketball
team and of course I knew I was gonna
play basketball and baseball and it's
do all the sports whatever and so I went
with him to this banquet of course he
could drive he was already he was
already gonna be a senior and I was like
this is my first like exposure to the
group of people that I will be going to
the school with at least in the athletes
even more pressure here mm-hmm and I
remember what I wore I had on this
t-shirt tucked in to khaki shorts and
the khaki shorts were very long and big
I'm sure it went down too but still
preppie it was a preppy look pleated
pleated khaki shorts that went to just
above the knee maybe just below the knee
it was right around the knees and then I
had a braided belt that was you know
purposely about 14 inches too long such
that it could be rolled around one time
and then put down the left leg and
struck me about mid thigh put down the
lip I know what you tell me you would
like tie a little knot in it and then it
comes down and going down it comes down
at a 90 degree angle perpendicular to
your bet your voice line
those are great you know a great thing
about a braided belt yes is unlimitedly
adjustable yeah cuz you can you can
stick the through it any part yeah any
place I can't believe they're not back
in maybe they will be I'd remember that
you wanted it to be long so you could
take it from east and flip it over and
turn it south yes and we also I had the
dock siders we called him those leather
shoes that she wore without socks and I
remember I'm so tan right now you know
we we had no regard for sunscreen or
anything so at the end of the summer in
the North Carolina summers you were just
as you were so tanned and you wanted to
show that off all the way up to the
ankle I remember just thinking about how
tanned my legs were you do yes I I was
in listen you know how skinny I was I
was so skinny I was so scrawny
I prom I was six four at the time and I
guarantee you I did not weigh more than
145 pounds I mean it was I mean there's
truth in the photos but I had all the
had completely no reason to have it but
all kinds of confidence all unfounded
confidence and I was the exam
opposite I was not confident did you get
feedback on the on the dock siders the
tan or the belt or anything I don't
recall
I don't recall specifically I just
remember feeling good about myself I
mean it didn't change I if I work it out
because the girls that you were obsessed
with I do remember swimming in our
secret spot in the Cape Fear River and
just talking for hours going into our
junior year so fast forward in two years
later and you were still obsessing about
like the next class the the upcoming
class of freshmen yeah it's it's it
sounds dirty to talk about it now but
you I mean it wasn't it was just a date
to have be in a relationship with the
woman I know but it was a girl but you
weren't about I just I don't know I but
you would just you'd say hey there's
there's this girl Melissa there's this
girl Stephanie it's like man one of them
can be your girlfriend one who can be my
girlfriend is like like it was that easy
it's not like you can just touch a girl
in the knee with your knee and then the
week late are you gonna be dating well
that did work that successfully well you
would talk we would talk cuz you would
really get you get me fired up about it
we were swimming
it like it was yesterday and we would it
was your confidence was so contagious I
did I became convinced that this girl
Melissa was going to be my girlfriend
I've never I never heard of her I've
certainly never seen her and I never had
met her yeah I was like double dates man
I was like we can drive now double dates
man and didn't course I'm on the soccer
team you're in the soccer team before
you besides before school starts and so
there's freshmen that are trying out for
the soccer team one of which turned out
to be Melissa's boyfriend so that kind
of like kind of informed how I moved
forward which was to not move forward at
all I mean I remember he was a freshman
yeah then which made me upset but yeah
my boss respected the boundaries I
wasn't gonna you got to push through
that my philosophy was you gotta push
through that this is high school these
relationships and how did that go for
you he's
relationships are not going to last okay
not gonna last
don't get too bent out of shape about
this stephanie was dating somebody to
man she never dated yeah I listen I told
you it was about confidence was
unfounded I have seen the pictures of
myself at that time and but the great
thing is is that I had this incredible
self-image I had no reason to
it's so weird we're 40 years old I mean
it was let's see I think it was last
Christmas when I was at home and I when
I was in the Zacks piece and Stephanie
walked in oh I saw Stephanie you did at
the Zaxby's how was she with her mom and
all of her kids her husband wasn't there
but I went up and you know I was getting
a refill on the drink you can do that
exactly I was there before she was she
sat down didn't see me and I saw her
when I was coming back with my drink and
I went over there I was like hey she
recognized me immediately we we chatted
it up for a few minutes I met her kids
you didn't come up once good but it is
funny it's simpler that way it's funny
that I immediately went back to uh
swimming in the river and like obsessing
about like oh she's gonna be my
girlfriend but this is gonna be your
girlfriend I tried man I tried a whole
lot more than I was successful I I've
told the story and again it it I don't
like talking about it now because it
movies are real people that still exist
well no and now we're 40 I don't know
how to say this in a in a way that will
make sense times have changed
Vick Utley since that time and and and
to think that I was so focused on just
getting a girlfriend and not and again I
was doing other things I you know we
both excelled at our academics and to
some degree our athletics you had that
game with the two goals with your left
foot it was amazing I'll never forget it
I think we did other things we had
really good friends we did a lot of cool
things that we wrote about in the book
and we spent a lot of time camping and
all we did a lot of other cool stuff but
it was kind of always I was always
distracted by this thought that I needed
to be in a relationship with somebody
and I just wish that I
could have I could go back and tell
myself don't think about that so much
don't worry you're gonna think you
couldn't think about it because who you
are but just don't it's not all it's
cracked up to be don't you worry about
this don't we you know wish that you're
in a relationship and forget about just
enjoying this time because when I think
about it I think that was it was just
this it sort of clouded every single
thing that I experienced at the time
well are are you talking to me right now
are you talking to the ear biscuit ears
or are you talking to your kids because
I do think that's that my kids are a
good way I think that's my kids are I
believe significantly healthier in this
regard and I do think part of it is we
have were constantly reminded them about
not because I know the way my kids think
and I can already see the patterns of
the way their brains work yeah my wife
can see that we see ourselves in them
and we know kinds of the things that
like oh this is the kind of thing I wish
I had told myself
and so I'm who do I have to tell now
I've got my kid yeah I think that's
that's a really cool thing about
parenting in general is when you can see
the wheels turning in your kids brain I
mean I've I've mentioned anxiety a lot
in this episode from you know my
childhood and I can see when that pops
up in in my kids lives and so it's cool
to be able to kind of speak to code
because well we know that it's our fault
right whatever it is it's like okay
there's this obsessive quality about
fill-in-the-blank or an anxious
interaction with something and we are
responsible for it whether directly
genetically or something that we screwed
up as a parent but it's cool to be able
to kind of hey you know you we have
talks and it's kind of like you're
speaking like they're shortcuts because
and you can see them light up like well
you kind of read my mail so to speak you
know how my brain works yeah so I think
that's pretty cool I mean I think it and
it's also cool to read to relive
vicariously the their newness of school
you know and I think that it is the type
of thing that I do find myself getting
charged up this time of year like I know
the traffic is gonna be worse again I
know my my kids aren't sleeping in and I
gotta help them get out of the house and
yeah you know there are some negatives
but then there's this energy it's kind
of it's the energy that precedes the
next energy which is fall energy like
remembering how leaves would fall back
east but still the air gets a little
crisper so this is and and then you got
like the holiday magic so it's like you
move him from one thing to the next in
that newness but I said that we would
talk a little bit about the science of
why we still feel this and why you even
if you don't go to school anymore you
may feel there's back-to-school feeling
so there's this article on NBC News that
talks about there's a number of reasons
for this one of them is the fact that
you your brain has sort of ingrained
this pattern that you may not even be
conscious of of like okay summers the
days are naturally longer you fill those
days more with more leisure time and
they kind of shape themselves in a
different way because just the amount of
light in the day and then when the
amount of light begins to decrease as
summer is coming to a close it actually
changes your circadian rhythms and
actually changes your melatonin levels
and stuff you sleep differently and if
you reinforce that every single year
there's this very transitional thing
that is happening where you're starting
a new fresh and it's in sync with the
changing of the seasons your brain has
become accustomed to that and it's just
the way our culture has is also in that
rhythm and you see it in the in the
back-to-school ads and that kind of
thing and so you've got those thoughts
and those feelings and all the stuff
that we kind of hinted at that continues
to come back and so it's actually the
you know the plasticity of your brain
it's ingrained in there and then if you
continue to do things like we do like
whether it is you've got a show that
comes back and is on that same cycle
you've got children who start school at
the same time you're going to feel that
feeling even before you
they register what's going on that's
kind of the very high level well that's
cool because it goes beyond just feeling
it vicariously through kids if you've
got them or just reminiscing or and it
it's something that you've built it's
also an argument for not the not doing
those year-round schools because there's
there's there's stripping kids these
days of the back-to-school sensation
yeah well I don't know I don't I don't
know even then they they they do have I
think there is a longer break during the
summer even for those kids I don't know
I haven't even I hate it so much I
haven't looked into it no I just never
experienced it and neither of my kids
but I know that a lot of people do but I
I think it's a great thing to embrace
you know if there's any way to to
embrace newness to assess and expect you
know I think any any moment when you can
do that is great you know I feel like
even professionally we're kind of in a
moment where it's we we've geared back
up with good mythical morning which
we're starting to get back into the
rhythm of that but we're also buckling
down on other things that we're working
on okay everybody you know this is this
is this is that sweet spot get some
stuff going so it's you know those
you're out of that lackadaisical summer
summer things so I think it's something
that if it's in your brain you can
harness you know this is a time this is
the time to make that change it's like
it's like it kind of feels like the new
year's resolution vibe but it doesn't
have all that weight of the anticipation
of breaking the resolution as much it's
looser than that and it's more about
it's more about the energy man well and
you think about you know especially
especially at that time between you know
middle school from middle school to the
end of high school you think about how
much a person changes I mean you just
look at pictures
okay I look at my kids I'll get luck and
how much he's just changed in the past
couple of years yeah and it's this mind
blowing and think about how much we have
changed in one sense but haven't changed
over the time like when you say Oh fall
again I'm like I want to turn 41 it's
like I'm gonna be I just I was just
having my awesome 40th birthday you
remember that one you know yeah and the
one that everybody talked about yeah and
now I'm gonna be 41 I'm gonna have some
awesome party for my 41st no cuz I'm 41
who cares
41 what no significance there but it
happened so quickly
whoa what tap back into that let's try
it right now okay it's happen to what
don't don't tap into your 41 miss yeah
but you started talking about like the
years and I started I'm gonna be 41 man
no no no just that Merle Haggard song
I'm 41 years old and I got no place to
go when it's over
[Music]
so I'll hide my age and make the stage
and try to kick the footlights out again
mmm again this is the best album hide my
age link it's what I'm gonna keep doing
how did how did this part try to kick
the footlights out of it how did it turn
into this embrace the newness that is
back to school I think I need to go back
to school I think I need to go to
Community College I think ultimately
that is what I've just decided
yeah what about real estate school I
might order I think I needed my classic
could drive a nice car at Pasadena
Community College all the ads say that
it's the best Community College in the
nation
what would the ads say it's we're a
pretty good Community College when you
look when you consider the nation we're
not the best but PCC man can you see me
at PCC just got a real estate school
short real Escape School is that for
escape rooms yeah it's how to get out of
his game I need to go to that school it
I get so frustrated by the group on with
me
me we're going to the real escape school
and like weekend just a couple of days
we can get out of any escape room we
need to teach that class because there
are so many people whose nights are
ruined because they get stuck at some
part of an escape room first of all I
need to take the class we know we need
to invent the class I just did we go to
all the escape rooms and we get all the
secrets we have to pay for that but then
we get our investment back when we
charge people to come learn how to get
out of these escape room I think it's as
simple as setting up a booth outside of
escape rooms with a map with a map well
it's just a British little guy we could
do it in an app and she just we don't
have to be there we just sell it as an
app you click on the app you want to go
to this escape route they don't let you
use your phones in escapers it's gonna
have to be printed okay dot matrix k
it's a PDF it's pdfs right what we can
laminate them we sell PDFs I wanted
people to download it and we're paid
download no but they call the phone out
of an escape room if you have a PDF I
can pirate that you need a lantern
either folded yet laminated brochure
level here's the cool thing though we
get better at selling the secrets to the
skate rooms they change they adapt they
become better
it's like coevolution I get it do you
hear that they started playing the music
I think it's okay
they've been fading us out slowly okay
so we've continued to talk about it so
let's just do that I'll take this too I
did back to the drawing board share with
a friend of yours this is episode of
your biscuits if you want to that's a
big help to us let's continue this
conversation using hash tag ear biscuits
reminisce about your back-to-school
feeling even if you're still having it
now and you're not in school even better
let us know yeah if you want to see me
I'll be on campus at Pasadena Community
College teaching the real escape class
so what what were you saying what so
let's keep going just me and you yeah
good luck with that
[Music]